now these things are very similar to
each other okay the Cartesian plane and
the this thing I call it the complex
plane but just like the Cartesian plane
it has a name that's attached to a
French mathematician his name with Zhang
Robair argot all right now we therefore
call this when you see it's real and
imaginary not real and real not a
Cartesian plane this is what we call an
Argand diagram okay minor minor
difference okay but it's important you
understand you label up here right you
know how are you seven and eight when we
introduced quite in geometry we obsessed
over label your axes it's super super
important right or there's a big
difference between a pair of real
numbers and a real and imaginary all
right now remember we said before you
can write a number as a plus bi but I
said you could also write it as X plus
iy okay so now you can see why it makes
sense to use x and y instead i'll just a
and b which is what you're literally
like can you imagine some mathematicians
like what's the first two that is like a
big ol am be right but then someone said
actually no answer why is going to make
sense because everything i know about
the cartesian plane can help me
spatially and geometrically okay so
that's why you'll see either of these
they're equally comment does this make
sense okay now while you've got an
Argand diagram there let's hijack a
little bit let's put some extra stuff on
there okay I can now represent any
number i like onto this eigen diagram
right any complex number so for instance
if I think of a number like say as an
example let's put where I cut some space
on let's go to plus
okay there's a complex number your age
to your beers beers one it's just a
single imaginary unit now where is he
going to go on this diagram right well
the real part of it the real part of it
tells me I should go to 22 and the
imaginary part tells me I can where am I
on its axis you told me that b is equal
to one so I should go up one year right
that's three eyes here we go so that guy
there that point is two plus iron right
that go there so now you can see how I
can extend my first definition remember
this right we said single decimal
expansion that's nice for real numbers
right there's not enough for complex so
we expanded it in the same way everyone
real number that you know about is a
point on a line but complex numbers
aren't just points online their points
on are on a game diagram more generous
meeting just a plan anything two
dimensions okay so it's a point
okay now we need some language here
right because you can see the way that
I've drawn 2 plus I demonstrates that
you've actually shaded off here a
rectangle right so therefore when you
write a number like this 2 plus I a plus
bi x plus my way we give that three
different names okay just to confuse you
right the first name is just can you put
it in X plus iy form right like we
literally just name the form okay
secondly because it's like a rectangle
right cuz it's like a rectangle we also
often call that this is actually my
favorite names my personal records we
call the rectangular form because if you
combine any a and B you like that will
combine that will draw out for you a
rectangle yeah lastly because of this
parallel I'm going to teach you a fancy
fancy word stay with this color which is
that the Cartesian plane a pair of real
numbers right x and y x2 y2 line it
behaves it in much the same way as our
pair of numbers here even though what's
real and imaginary so the fancy what we
use is we say that the Cartesian plane
the set of a pair of real numbers is
isomorphic to the complex time to where
you have a real number chemical than
imagined
combined to death okay because they're
so similar because they're so similar in
addition to being called rectangular
form we also call it Cartesian form
Cartesian form okay and all of these
means say thanks if you see any of them
rather than this form computer in that
form etc they all mean like this yeah so
it's not like different forms like 1500
how do you couldn't have given me a
better vintage introduction into the
next part the show that situation is
correct right so when you say point
great inform general form Isabel etc we
actually want to look different but all
of these are different names for the
same thing in a similar way that when
you say are dy on d x or y dash right or
alternatively like f dash x those are
all the different ways to dress up it's
literally the same thing we just mean
the first derivative okay first
derivative there's another name for the
same object does that make sense so
these are all different names for the
same object okay